So, we can think about some general principles that one, has to keep in
mind as an OS designer in designing
operating systems for earlier machines. The first principle
is of course cashe conscious decisions. What
that means is, you want to pay attention
to locality. Exploit affinity to caches in
scheduling decisions for instance. And you want to reduce
the amount of sharing of data structures. If you reduce
the amount of sharing of data structures, you're reducing contention. So,
limit the amount of sharing to system data structures. We've
seen this when we talked about different synchronization algorithms. We talked
about how we can reduce the amount of sharing of
the system data structure, so that we can limit the amount
of contention, that's important to do, and the other thing that
you want to do is, you want to keep the memory
accesses local to every node in the multiprocessor as
possible, and basically what that means is you're reducing
the distance between the accessing processor and the memory.
Already, the distance is pretty big when you go
outside the chip, and access the memory over here.
But, the distance is even more if you have
a traverse interconnection network. And reach into a memory
that is on a different node of the multiprocessor.
So, keeping memory access local is another important principle that
you want to adhere to in designing operating system for, multiprocessors.